this is a production of Cornell
University
uh I'm going to talk to you today about
uh what has been the majority of my
teachers were here trying to understand
the long-term effects of contrasting
organic cropping systems on the
communities
um so to start off I just want to ask
why do we care about weed communities in
organic agriculture
well weeds are consistently cited as the
top production challenge by organic
farmers
and while proactive weed management is
important in every agricultural system
it takes on extra
it takes on extra importance in organic
agriculture where you don't have
herbicides to deal with unexpected weed
infestations
however ProActive Management doesn't
work if you're treating single species
as individual problems with this
approach successful control of a single
species can just lead to weed Community
shifts as new species fill in the gaps
uh right that's called a species
treadmill and it's not a good situation
as you can see
okay so it's more effective to design
cropping systems that will manage the
weed Community as a whole so the idea
here is that you adopt a suite of
management practices that work together
to keep any one weed species from
becoming problematic
of course that's easier said than done
in order to do that you need to know how
individual management practices as well
as your cropping system as a whole
interact with the weed community
so to help understand this interaction
between management and Lead communities
I want to talk about plant Community
assembly for a minute so this is a
concept that's been developed in the
ecological literature to try to describe
how Community we our plant communities
seen in these uh pie charts over here on
the right are formed from a regional
species School represented by these
letters on the left
and Community assembly conceptualizes
this process as a series of filtering
procedures so you have dispersal filters
to get to your site in the first place
as well as environmental or abiotic
filters things like light water
temperature and then biotic filters as
well so competition predation things
like that and only by successfully
passing through these filters will a
species from the regional pool end up in
your community that you observe
so actually this concept can be pretty
easily applied to Agro ecosystems when
you want to think about weed Community
assembly
so similar to your natural systems
you'll have your Regional pool of weeds
that could potentially colonize your
farm fields and similarly they have to
disperse to that farm field in the first
place and pass through abiotic and
biotic filters already in place
however now we also have management
filters on top of that
and those can be things like the
herbicide that you spray on the field
your tillage system the crop you plant
and even the fertilizer you put on the
field
and even if a species can make it
through these initial filters it won't
necessarily make it through the
management filters as well so you can
think of maybe if you spray herbicide on
a field you'll select for species that
have herbicide resistance and those
might be the only ones you see in the
community
but you can also think of examples from
organic agriculture if you do intensive
spring tillage you might end up
selecting for species that can germinate
after that disturbance event
or if you put a lot of fertilizer on the
field you might end up intensifying
competition for light and selecting for
species that can grow tall and
accumulate that nitrogen
the idea here is that your cropping
system is acting as a series of
management filters that assemble this
weed community that you observed and
importantly this cropping says these
filters are acting on the weed traits
not on the weed species identity itself
so a horse weed for instance is not
being filtered because it's a horse weed
because it would have herbicide
resistance so that herbicide resistance
germination season height these are all
traits I mentioned here so remember that
for later
okay
so it turns out we actually know quite a
bit about how these weed communities
respond to management
so for instance in no-till versus more
conventionally tilled systems we know
that no-till can increase weed abundance
and weed diversity as well as select for
annual grasses that can germinate on the
surface and perennial species that might
otherwise have their life cycles
interrupted by tillage
and on a system level there's evidence
that organic agriculture increases weed
diversity relative to herbicide-based
systems however organic agriculture is
not monolithic right despite the fact
that there might be smaller differences
between organic cropping systems organic
farmers still have a lot of choices when
it comes to designing their cropping
systems
and despite the centrality of weed
management inorganic there's a lot less
known about how these weed communities
in organic cropping systems compare to
each other
so this left an open question that
really became the focus of my thesis so
I wanted to know if contrasting organic
cropping systems still assemble distinct
weed communities
and to approach this question I wanted a
way to measure the weed community that
could integrate the effects of organic
management over time
so for that I turned to the weed seed
bank and the weed seed bank is just the
collection of all the weed seeds in the
soil on a farm field
and um because a lot of weed species
exhibit seed dormancy the seeds in the
seed bank aren't all necessarily from
the most recent season so you can also
have a lot of dormant seeds from past
Seasons with management and so by
sampling this weed seed bank you get a
clearer window into the cumulative
effects of a cropping system on the weed
community
however I still needed some sort of
study system to sample the seed bank in
that had been explicitly comparing
organic cropping systems for long enough
for their effects on the weed Community
to stabilize
so that's where the Cornell organic
cropping systems experiment came in
so this is a long-term systems
experiment comparing four organic green
cropping systems it's just up at the
Musgrave research farm and it was
started in 2005
so almost 20 years old now
and it's set up as a split pot
randomized complete block design
with four organic cropping systems as
the main plot treatments which I'll go
through in a minute as well as two entry
points into the crop rotation as the
subplot treatment and that just means
within each main plot one of the
subplots started on one crop in the
rotation the other one started on a
different crop and that's just a way to
ensure that each crop was planted twice
during the rotation to control for some
sort of year-to-year climate and
management variability without having to
plan every single crop in every year
which would be called a full entry
design
okay so the cropping systems in OCS are
all sort of designed as different Paths
of success and viability on Organic
Farms
first you have the high fertility system
which says that if you increase your
fertilizer application you can maximize
your yields and thereby increase your
profit
the low fertility system takes slightly
opposite View and says that you can
decrease those inputs on the front end
to save that money up front
in hand Suite management system more
specifically focuses on decreasing weed
competition to increase yield and
increase profit whereas reduced tillage
takes a slightly different pact and says
if you decrease disturbance you can
build soil health and that has been
shown to uh lead to resilience and
stabilized yields in the long term
okay so these four cropping systems
exist on two primary management
gradients
the first is a fertility gradient so
reduce telogen enhanced weed management
get an intermediate level of fertility
high fertility got a 50 higher rate of
fertilizer in many of the crops low
fertility got a 50 lower rate there's
also a disturbance gradient from
enhanced weed management which had
additional cultivation passes in many of
the crops for in-season weed control and
reduce to reduce tillage which had
primary tillage that was either less
intense or displaced or removed at
various points in the rotation in order
to build soil health
and all four of these cropping systems
went through the same rotation from
Spring 2018 to fall 2021. and I'm going
to run through that rotation real
quickly uh just from where it started in
entry point a remember there's two entry
points into this rotation so entry point
a started in 2018 with triticale
which was followed by red clover that
overwintered and was used as a green
manure for a corn crop that corn crop
had a cover crop under seated
of Cyril Rye red clover yellow Blossom
Sweet Clover and Italian rye grass which
overwintered and was followed by a
summer forage crop of sorghum Sudan
grass and pearl millet
followed by Cyril Rye which overwintered
and was followed finally by soybean
and remember entry point B has a
different place it starts at zero right
the zero right soybean part of the
rotation but and ends at the summer
Forge
okay so within these crops there were
there were slight management differences
between these systems to keep in line
with the philosophies of the broad
philosophies of the property systems
so high fertility enhanced weed
management had the red clover Frost
seeded into triticale and that
critically harvested off for grain
afterwards grew
and then the triticalian the reduced
tillage and low fertility systems was
harvested through forage to make room
for a false seed bed before the red
clover was planted in these two systems
we also had the zero Rye uh rolled down
for no-till soybean planting
whereas in the in high fertility and
enhanced weed management the zero ride
was harvested through for forage and
then there was tillage done for soybean
planting into the bare ground
okay so with all those differences in
mind I want to return to This research
question right do these contrasting
organic cropping systems assemble the
same feed communities
and my hypothesis here was that given
enough time even comparatively minor
management differences can act as
Community assembly filters to produce
distinct wheat communities and that I
would be able to see these uh
differences in the feedback
okay so to approach this hypothesis I
had to measure the seed bank
so what we did was choose soil seed bank
Greenhouse emergence assays one in 2017
was done before my time and one in 2022
that I did
um and that involves taking 25 soil
cores from each of the subplots in the
experiment combining them together and
laying them out in the greenhouse
and then identifying the seedlings that
emerged over three flushes to try to
exhaust the seed bank
we also collected emergent weed biomass
in each of the crops in the rotation in
between just to get some sort of idea of
what was going on in the wheat Community
between the seed bank endpoints
from this weed Community data I
calculated several response variables
and I'll go through all of these
and then I ran generalized linear mixfx
models trying to see if these response
variables could be predicted by the
cropping system entry point and year as
well as all of their interactions and
then I also added spatial random effects
to these models
from there I tested the significance of
these fixed effects using type 3 Anova
and ran post-hoc comparisons on the
marginal means for the cropping systems
to see which cropping systems were
significantly different from each other
okay now we can get into some results
so I'm going to start with seed bank
density
and what I'm showing you here
is the seed bank density for just entry
point a here on the y-axis you see C
density adjusted to seeds per meter
squared and then the x-axis is just the
two years of sampling and then you have
each system high fertility is in red
reduced tillage in green low fertility
in blue enhanced weed management and
orange these are going to be the colors
throughout
um and some other things to notice uh
within each year here uh this two
cropping systems with the same letter
are not significantly different from
each other and you might also notice
that the 2017 letters are lowercase and
the 2022 letters are uppercase and I did
this to indicate that there's a
significant interaction between year
entry point and cropping system here so
the postdoc comparisons were only done
within each level of year
laughs
okay and then the asterisks there in
2022 are just indicating whether the
change from 2017 to 2022 within a system
was significant
okay so just looking at this ladder plot
here
um it seems like maybe high fertility is
increasing seed bank density uh over
this time period where maybe reduced
tillage is decreasing seed bank density
but I also want to show you the emergent
biomass that we took
so here you have weed biomass on the
y-axis in kilograms per hectare and then
along the x-axis you have all the crops
that were planted in entry point a in
chronological order
and there's a key for for them up here
but what I really want you to focus on
is the last two crops 2021 here
so here we have zero Rye CR that has
good weed control across the board at
very low bars
but if you look at soybean SB you can
see that there was actually a failure of
weed control in the build system so the
enhanced weed Management in Orange and
especially in high fertility in red
where there was pretty good weed
Management in the no-till systems
reduced tillage and low fertility
and so through this lens
if you look at this seed bank density
graph again it seems like maybe this
increase in high fertility could be
explained by an influx of weed seeds
into the seed bank from all this biomass
just before seed bank sampling in 2022
rather than some manifestation of a
long-term Trend and I want to drive this
home by showing you entry point B so
here in entry point B where don't see
that increase in the high fertility
system in fact it seems like all of the
systems either decreasing or staying the
same and kind of coming closer together
and here's the weed biomass data for
entry point B again just focus on these
last crops here and the saf is the
summer forward crop that's where it
ended in entry point B and what you see
here are two things first that there's
no significant differences between the
systems here and second that the weed
control is pretty good across the board
um and so when you look back at the C
Bank density graph again these results
seem to make sense in this context that
there was good weed control right before
the seed bank sampling maybe a few
received going in
so what this tells me all together is
the success or lack of success of weed
control in your recent crops appears to
be masking any long-term influences
profit system on seed bank density
but that didn't happen for every
response variable that I calculated so
here I want to show you Shannon
diversity which is just a taxonomic
diversity measure that takes into
account both for species richness the
number of species in the community and
their relative abundance
and Shannon diversity looked like this
again here we have these four systems
but here you might notice the letters
are on the center of the lines and I did
that to indicate the lack of an interest
right there's no interaction between
year entry point and cropping system
instead the differences are driven by
cropping systems
and what we're seeing in that in those
results is that the reduced tillage
system has the highest weed diversity
enhanced weed management has the lowest
and the other two systems are somewhere
in between
and if that looks familiar that's
because that's the disturbance gradient
of these systems
so it appears like lower disturbance is
increasingly diversity and higher
disturbance and decreasingly diversity
and as I told you before this isn't
necessarily new we know that no-till
versus conventional pills can increase
weed diversity but what we're seeing
here is that even with these
comparatively smaller differences
between these organic systems we're
still seeing this trend manifest
however we aren't really seeing a
difference between the uh hypertelain
and voltage like our fertility radius in
here
okay
so while looking at seed bank density
and Shannon diversity uh can tell you
some really interesting things about
your weed Community remember I told you
that the community assembly filters act
on traits of weeds not on the species
identity which is how these are
calculated
um so to really get at my hypothesis
about these cropping systems acting as
Community assembly filters I had to look
at functional traits and these are just
morphological physiological or
phenological traits that have some
bearing on plant growth reproduction
survival that could be anything from the
seed Mass whether it's an annual or
perennial whether it's aggressor
broadleaf
um and it turns out there's a lot of
literature out there
um demonstrating how these different
functional traits respond to different
management gradients so using that
literature I was able to pick out six uh
continuous and four categorical traits
that I suspected would respond to the
primary Management gradients in the OCS
systems
and using trait databases I was able to
find values for every species that I saw
in the seed bank for all of these crates
and then I was able to calculate several
metrics to help me test my hypothesis
about Community assembly
the first of these is something called a
community weighted mean
and this is just the abundance weighted
average of a trade value in a community
to illustrate this here I have Community
one which is an even mix of all medium
and short species and here I have
Community 2 which is dominated by Tall
Grass species
so if you look at a continuous trait
like height here you have Community 2
with a higher Community rated Union bite
because of those tall grasses dominating
the abundance whereas you have a lower
one in community one
you can also calculate these for
categorical traits for that you just
figure out the abundance that fits into
each category or each level of your
categorical variable so here this this
community too has more grasses
two-thirds grasses so it's 0.67 versus
0.33 it's reversed in the other one
foreign
is I calculated these Community weighted
means for all of these different traits
and what that gave me was a series of
new response variables that I could run
in my models that I used for seed
density and for diversity
and I don't really have time
unfortunately to go through the results
for every single one of those that you
can read my thesis if you want to
but I want to focus here on uh
germination season so germination season
is a phenological categorical variable
that describes the general time of year
when a weed species tends to germinate
and emerge in a farm field and I split
this into fall to early spring
mid-spring and late spring to Summer
germinating species
so here's what we see for germination
season
here on the um on the y-axis you just
have that proportion of abundance that
fits into each of these categories
right and in the fall to early for fall
to early spring germinating species you
consistently see across years and entry
points uh more fall to early spring
germinating species in the high
fertility in red and reduced Village
degree in those systems
and these are species like common
chickweed or purple dead nettle it might
have benefited from a history of light
spring tillage in the reduced tillage
system or in the high fertility system a
history of uh higher fall fertilizer
applications
in the other uh on the other hand we see
more late spring to Summer germinating
species than the other two systems
enhance weed management and low
fertility
and these are things like witch grass
and hedge binding and again you can
think of some possible mechanistic
explanations for why this might happen
uh in the low fertility system lower
fertilizer applications might delay crop
canopy closure and allow these later
emerging species to get out above the
canopy
whereas in the enhanced weed management
system those cultivation passes
extending into the summer could select
your species that can only emerge that
could still emerge after those
cultivation passes were done
and the trends for every trait were not
this clear obviously but here we're
seeing
very clear evidence of these cropping
systems acting as Community assembly
filters selecting for certain trait
values relative to each other
and the final thing I want to show you
is a functional dispersion so if you can
think of the community weighted means
that I was showing you as more of the
center or average of the trait
distribution in your community
functional dispersion is helpful to
think of functional dispersion as more
of the spread or variability in those
traits in your community and so the
higher variability or higher spread of
trait values you have in your community
in general the higher functional
diversity you have there's more
functional trait combinations that can
exist in that community
mm-hmm
and so uh here's what we see oh actually
I was gonna say this is a good
functional analog for pain and diversity
in that way because it's like functional
diversity versus taxonomic diversity and
surprise
um what you see is is uh a trend driven
by cropping system just like with
Shannon diversity right so here we see
the the reduced tillage system and the
low fertility system have the highest
functional dispersion the highest
functional diversity and this could be
because these are somewhat of our lower
input systems they might be applying
fewer or weaker or softer filters on the
weed community and allowing more
functional trade combinations to exist
okay that's what I told you
um so in conclusion I just want to come
back to my research question here right
do contrasting organic cropping systems
assemble distinctly communities and I
think given this evidence we can give
this a yes
so more specifically these cropping
systems are selecting for different
functional traits in weed communities
and thereby acting as Community assembly
filters and I showed you the example
here of germination seasonality where
the high fertility and low and reduced
tillage systems appear to be selecting
for these pool season or fall to early
spring germinating species
we also saw that lower tillage intensity
or nutrient applications in the reduced
tillage and low fertility systems
are increasing our taxonomic and or
functional weed diversity and so
um more diverse weed communities are
increasingly associated with decreased
yield loss due to weed competition as
well as increased ecosystem services so
even benefits to pollinators or pest
control things like that
um and again I told you before organic
systems have been associated with an
increase in diversity relative to
herbicide-based systems but what we're
seeing here is that even within organic
systems on uh with smaller differences
between them we still see these changes
manifesting you're still changing your
diversity and what that tells me is that
the small changes organic farmers make
can make a difference so for instance
say a farmer can't go to a fully no-till
system they could still accrue these
essential benefits of weed diversity by
integrating rotational no-till or
something into their system where it
makes sense
finally we also did see that recent
management can rapidly change seed bank
density that was the first result that I
showed you there and what this really
tells me is the importance of an
integrated weed management strategy
right so if you impose a greater
diversity of these management filters on
the weed Community you're going to
minimize the chance that any one species
or like functional trait combination is
uh continuously selected for and thereby
can dominate the community and compete
very heavily with your crop
so take it all together I'm really
hopeful that this research can help
organic farmers start to align their
cropping system design with their weed
management goals there's a lot of
different options out there organic
farmers when it comes to designing a
system making these choices but there's
a lot less research done on how those
choices affect the weed communities in
the end and these are the things that
the farmers are going to have to manage
so I'm hoping that this can fill that
Gap
um and then I just want to thank
everybody involved with the organic
cropping systems experiment especially
Brian Caldwell Dr Chuck Moller and our
organic farmer advisory committee who
really helped conceptualize and get this
thing off the ground and keep it running
in the beginning and then we have
everyone in the Ryan and drink water
Labs who have been running even up until
now there's props out there in the field
currently
um and then on a more personal note I
just want to thank all of my loved ones
family and friends for the continued
support throughout this two-year journey
and into whatever comes next uh but I
can offload big questions now I think
I don't know that much about weed so I
apologize in advance if it's not a very
educated question but um so you're
looking at how it's affecting the
community but what what about what
actual effect it has on the cross would
you also look at how it affects us it
seems like
you could have a lot of weeds because
it's not affecting your products maybe
it doesn't matter so much yeah that's
definitely
um
something to consider with this study so
we do have yield data from the organic
cropping systems experiment so it is
available
um
it just wasn't included in this research
particularly but one of the weaknesses
is that we don't necessarily have a weed
free plot within those
um within those experimental plots so we
don't really know based on how the yield
is changing how much of that is due to
how the lead Community has changed so it
would be really good to get some
and there have been some experiments
done showing
um with those weed tree plots how much
of the changes in yields can be
attributed to uh the changes that you
see in the new community so right we
don't know necessarily if those fall to
early spring germinating species are
competing more or less with the crop and
what that's doing to the yield and that
is as you say super important so
the way that I think about this is more
of like uh these functional trait
conclusions can provide General guidance
to Farmers as they're trying to design a
cropping system that might help with the
problematic leads they anticipate so you
don't want to necessarily choose one
that's going to be selecting for very
competitive winter annual weeds when
you're trying to grow winter wheat or
something like that so definitely that's
something that needs to be done more
thank you
um I was wondering uh
and again I
don't know either so uh
how much of the how much farmers are
trying or in those in the experiments
are trying to prevent weeds from
shedding seeds
and artists shouldn't see like
throughout the whole system or normally
you try in just a small fraction of the
wheat population will end up building a
food bank
yeah that's a good that's a good
question I think that in it varies from
crop to crop in the bandwidth that uh
Chris tells her our field manager has
for uh doing post Harvest weed control
and stuff
um but in several of the crops like for
instance uh the red clover and the
rotation uh it was left in the field for
a long time so there was a lot of weed
growth happening and we might do like a
mowing or something to stop a lot of
businesses so
to take your point further right like it
is it is definitely true that the feed
Bank might not be fully representative
of what's what's going on because if
you're not allowing certain weeds to
contribute their seeds you might end up
with a seed bank skewed towards maybe
like smaller species
she had a lot more seeds without growing
tall than getting Motors
okay
adds to the complexity
complexity is the key word
I feel like I'd like to ask a lot a lot
more follow-up questions but I just
limited from one as an example because
you had those four
um uh the poor treatment let's call it
and one of them is uh reduce tillage
which has a lot of benefits in terms of
soil health and so forth but I'm
confused how are you controlling weeds
in that case could you just elaborate a
little bit on what does that entail
reduce tillage as a one of the options
and it's and you're looking at weed seed
production yeah
um so it's varied over the life of the
experiment in the beginning when this
was first established 2005 to 2010 in
the first couple of occasions reduced
tillage was
um
almost a failure of a system someone
like there was a lot of weeds they were
trying to do a like experimental Bridge
tillage system and there was a lot of
weed seed produced in those years
um and over the years we've sort of like
in conversation with the organic farm
Advisory Board figured out ways to try
to reduce that so you notice that I said
even in the reduced tillage system there
is a false seed bed done and that was
specifically included due to
recommendations by Chuck Muller about
doing those no-till soybeans and then
going into the triticale you need to
clean up your field to like decrease the
weed seed bank right because it was
gonna there was gonna be too many seeds
coming from the motel part
um and what you see actually I didn't
present this part but um
due to the fact that we've had to maybe
ramp up some tillage and then reduce
tillage system over the past rotation
more moldboard plow passes for instance
um you actually see the weed communities
converging a little bit so whereas the
reduced tillage system may be used to
have a slightly different Community
because it was more experimental now
that it's time to like focus more on how
can we actually make this profitable
it's sort of the way community they're
converging a bit and we're doing in the
next rotation try to make it diverge
while still making a profit it's an
iterative
systems trial but yeah
so I think we're going to stop here for
questions uh let's thank our speaker
all right everyone
um as Matt just said my name is Annika
Roland and today I'm going to be talking
about integrated weed management and
organic no-till soybeans
so I know Jake just briefly mentioned
integrated weed management but today I'm
really going to talk about how we can
optimize this system
so integrated weed management is when
several weed management management
strategies are used together in a single
growing season
these weed management strategies can
include mechanical chemical biological
or cultural practices
and a key thing about integrated weed
management is that if a farmer uses
multiple practices and one tactic fails
other tactics can fill in management
gaps
in addition using multiple practices
will reduce selection for adaptive
species
like Jake said if a farmer is using
purely herbicides
they might find that those weeds become
competitive in herbicide resistant
integrated weed management can also lead
to synergistic interactions between
tactics
this means that when tactics are
combined they can produce a positive
effect that could not have been
predicted from the tactics performance
in isolation
a concept that comes out of integrated
weed management is this idea of many
little hammers which was coined by
Liebman and Gallant in 1997. so this is
when you combine multiple tactics which
may not be fully effective on their own
you can achieve holistic Management in a
system
so now let's talk about how weeds are
managed in organic production
so for decades tillage has been the main
way that weeds are managed tillage
disrupts the soil surface berries weed
residue and prepares the bed for
planting however if tillage is performed
intensively and without the addition of
other conservation practices
tillage can degrade soil health
increase soil erosion soil compaction
and ultimately reduce yields
therefore additional strategies
Solutions are needed to manage weeds in
organic production
organic rotational no-till planted
soybean has been a strategy that has
been studied extensively to manage weeds
in organic systems
this involves a fall planted cover crop
in this case cereal Rye which
overwinters and produces high amounts of
biomass in the spring
it is then roller crimped to create a
weed suppressive mulch The Mulch
suppresses weeds through physical
interference light interference and
allelocap allelopathy
soybean can get can then be planted
directly into that mulch
the equipment used for organic no-till
production is really important
this is a front mounted roller crimper
which can be filled with water to make
it a little bit heavier
and then the machine
moves over cereal rye and terminates it
but the cereal Rye Roots remain in the
ground which provides soil stability
and then we have our normal our no-till
planter which in this experiment was
attached to the rear of the tractor
so there are many important parts to the
no-till planter
but what's essential is that it slices
through that cereal Rye Mulch and allows
for adequate seed to soil contact
and does not disturb the cereal dry
mulch
and so now I'm going to show you a video
of this whole system in action in my
experience
sorry
if it's slow
so you see that the soybean is planted
directly into the cereal Rye mulch in a
single pass operation
so why would farmers want to adopt this
system what are the benefits
so previous research has found that this
system reduced Fuel and reduces Fuel and
labor costs by 27 and 31 respectively
when in the spring instead of tilling
and preparing the bed for soybean
planting a farmer can simply terminate
that cereal rye and plant soybean into
that mulch in addition the need for
additional cultivation events later on
in the season is not needed because that
cereal will rimulus suppresses the weeds
the cereal Rye residue can also preserve
soil moisture particularly later on in
the season when you might experience
drought the cereal Rye will limit
transpiration from that soiled surface
lastly using cover crops has been shown
to increase and improve soil health
the cover crops are planted in the fall
they overwinter there are roots in the
soil throughout the entire year this
increases carbon
sequestration will improve aggregate
stability in your soil and increase
water infiltration
so like I said you can achieve high
levels of cereal Rye Mulch and Achieve
adequate weed suppression
however sometimes you can get a field
like that looks like this where the
serial mulch fails to suppress weeds and
you have high levels of emergence
this is when additional weed management
tactics are needed in this system
and The crucial thing is that the added
weed management tactics should not
disrupt that serial right mulch
and so this is where my experiment comes
in soybean weed integrated management
I used I looked at three management
tactics which are compatible with this
organic no-till system
they were a high soybean seeding rate an
interro mower
and a weed zapper
and so we implemented these tactics
alone and in all possible combinations
so for my treatments I had an untreated
control where no weed management was
performed
we had a high soybean seeding rate into
row Mower and weed zapper treatments
just on their own
then we had all possible combinations of
the tactics implemented in twos in
individual treatments
and then a treatment where all three
tactics were combined
we also had a weed-free treatment which
was hand-weeded weekly until soybean
canopy
and my hypothesis was that a combination
of these weed management tactics would
be most effective at reducing weed
biomass and increasing soybean yields
my experiment was implemented at
Musgrave research Farm in Aurora New
York in 2021 in 2022
and I had two Fields each year that had
a range of cereal Rye mulch so one of
the fields had really high levels of
mulch and the other one had bare soil
which was meant to mimic extremely low
levels of mulch that a farmer might face
each field had a spatially balanced
randomized complete block design with
four blocks per field
for my statistical analysis I analyze my
response variables with linear mixed
effects models
and then I assess the fixed effects with
type 3 analysis of variance
and then I compared treatment levels
using least Square means with the
Fischer LSD method
for my sampling methods in August I
collected soybean biomass and soy and
weed biomass by species
and then in October I collected soybean
density and soybean yields and all
collections were performed with half
meter squared quadrat
so now I'm just going to review my
tactics so a high soybean seeding rate
will increase soybean density within
that soybean row and this will increase
the competitive the competitive ability
of soybeans
in addition increased soybean density
leads to faster canopy closure which
means that light will be intercepted and
not reach weed species that might
germinate at the soil surface
in my experiment the Baseline rate was
400 432
000 seats per hectare in the high
seeding rate was 680 000 seats per
hectare
so we chose these seeding rates because
they're slightly below and slightly
above the optimum economic seeding rate
for organic no-till planted soybean that
was found by my colleague udem nalid
this is the interim mower used in this
experiment so it has five individual
rotary mowers which move between soybean
rows there are shields on either side of
each mower that protect the soybean from
crop damage and they're about 66
centimeters wide
the interim mower Cuts weeds that are 5
to 15 centimeters above the soil surface
and in my experiment it was used twice
in both years of the experiment once six
weeks after planting and once eight
weeks after planting
and so now you're going to get to see a
little snippet of a video that I
produced with Jen Thomas Murphy about
the interro mower
[Music]
foreign
all right and now we'll talk about the
weed zapper so this was purchased from
Old School manufacturing and contains
two units the rear mounted generator and
the front mounted copper Boom the rear
mounted generator powers that front
copper boom with a PTO system
the front Mountain copper boom travels
over the soybean canopy so it really
takes advantage of that height
differential that can exist between the
top of a weed and the top of the soybean
canopy
yeah
when the copper boom contacts a weed it
can send up to 15 kilovolts of
electricity through a weed
and in this experiment the weed zapper
was used twice the first year of the
experiment once seven weeks after
planting and once 10 weeks after
planting and then once the second year
of the experiment about seven weeks
after planting
and here is a little snippet of another
video that I produced with Jen Thomas
Murphy about the weed zapper
foreign
[Music]
videos they are on the Cornell field
crops webpage
so I want to emphasize the spatial
aspect of these weed management tactics
so the high soybean seeding rate targets
weeds that are in that soybean row
the interro mower manages weeds that are
between the soybean row
and the weed zapper manages weeds above
the soybean canopy
there's also the import the temporal
aspect
the high soybean seeding rate is
implemented at planting
the interim interro mower was
implemented six to eight weeks after
planting and the weed zapper was used 7
to 10 weeks after planting so the fact
that these weed management strategies
Target weeds across time and space will
reduce the possibility of selecting for
a highly competitive species
so now we'll talk about some of my
results starting with soybean density
for all the graphs that I'll show you my
treatments are on the x-axis and my
response variables are on the y-axis
for soybean density
differences between letters here
indicate differences between means
and we find that with increased planting
rate soybean density also increased so
Sr here is high seeding rate
and this is really just a confirmation
that our high soybean seeding rate did
in fact work it also confirms that our
management tools did not negatively
impact soybean density
so now we'll get into weed biomass and
first we're going to look at our
individual weed management tactics I
apologize there should be error bars
there but they are not showing up on the
PowerPoint
um again differences between letters
indicates to indicate differences
between means
so in my experiment we found that when
oh sorry and I should point out so this
is the untreated control this is the
high seeding rate then we have the intro
Mower and then the weed zapper
so we find that the weed zapper reduced
weed biomass by 60 compared to the
control
I think that this is because the interim
mower targeted the highest proportion of
weeds in this system it was directly
reducing the weed biomass of every weed
that it came into contact with in that
66 centimeter space
the high soybean seeding rate did not
reduce weed biomass compared to the
untreated control
this might be because these seeding
rates were already quite High compared
to seeding rates used by other organic
producers so we might be at a point of
diminishing returns here where even if
we add additional
um like if we increase the seeding rate
we won't see increases in the
suppression of weeds
and with the weed zapper we also did not
see a decrease in weed biomass
and I think that this is because the
weed zapper actually did not kill a high
proportion of weeds there weren't many
weeds which grew way higher than that
soybean canopy to be hit by that copper
boom and if the weeds were hit they
tended to recover and were sampled for
weed biomass
now we have our combinations of tactics
and I just want to point out that every
tactic that
um
that included the interro mower
decreased weed biomass compared to the
untreated control
but when additional tactics were added
to interim mowing the weed biomass
didn't decrease further which suggested
the interim mower could be used alone
in this system to manage weeds
and so I did a dominant weed species
analysis where I looked at the top weed
species in our fields
and I found that a common Ragweed common
lamb squirter and yellow foxtail were
the most dominant species throughout all
fields in each year and then Venice
mallow black medic and ladies thumb also
there were high levels that varied
throughout the fields
and I want to point out here that five
of these six weed species are annual
dicot species
which brings me to my next point which
is the weed community so we separated
out
annual perennial dicot and monocot
species from the total weed biomass I
know you can't see it because the zoom
thing is there
um
so maybe I'll just wait until Matt okay
[Laughter]
so we separated out these different
traits to see if the weed management
tactics
selected for specific weed species
traits and so for our annual weed
biomass
yes
for our annual weed biomass we see that
every treatment that has the interim
mower in it
weed biomass was reduced compared to the
untreated control just like the total
weed biomass
for perennials there were no differences
across any of the treatments
for dicot weed species again the same
Trends as the annual in the total weed
biomass
and there were no differences from the
untreated control for the monocotweed
biomass
and as you can see
um the scales here they're all the same
so there's clearly higher amounts of
annual and dicot weed species than
perennial and monocot in the Swede
Community which suggests or tells us
that our weed Community was dominated by
annual annual dicot weeds that are
susceptible to interim mowing
and finally we'll talk about my soybean
yields so
we'll look at the individual tactics
again
so here we see that the intro mower
increased soybean yield compared to that
untreated control
I hypothesize that this is because the
intro mower reduced weed biomass during
the critical period of weed control
which is the period during soybean
growth when it is most essential to
manage weeds to prevent yield loss
the high soybean seeding rate did not
increase soybean yields compared to the
untreated control
this might have been because when the
soybeans were at planted at a higher
density they produced less pods per
individual plant
and with the weed zapper we also did not
see increases in soybean yields likely
because the weed zapper did not reduce a
high amount of weed biomass so those
weeds were competing with the soybean
crop
and then we look at our combinations of
tactics we find that the high seeding
rate the combination of the high seeding
rate in the intro mower as well as the
combination of all three tactics
increased yields compared to the
untreated control so those are the bars
here that it indicated with the letter b
and now we'll talk about the weed free
control which produced yields that are
were much higher than any other
treatment
and so this weed free control again was
hand-weeded weekly until soybean canopy
closure and provides a benchmark for
additional weed management strategies to
be added to the system
so now I want to talk about the cost of
these tactics
for the seeding rate the Baseline rate
would cost about 216 dollars per hectare
and the high seeding rate would cost
about 349 dollars per hectare and this
is organic soybean
we purchased the intro mower for this
experiment for about thirty thousand
dollars from our Tech Industries
and the weed zapper was purchased for
sixty nine thousand dollars from Old
School manufacturing although prices can
be up to 88 500 depending on the size of
the machine a farmer might order
I also want to talk about some
limitations of these tactics
with the interim mower we did find that
weeds regrue after mowing
we also found that there was soybean
injury could occur if the mower strayed
from the GPS tracks when going through
the field and of course this is
something that can happen with any form
of cultivation
thank you we also saw mulch disturbance
if there were high levels of mulch the
interim mower would chop The Mulch up
however we found that this didn't really
affect the volta's ability to suppress
weeds
then with the weed zapper
we found that if a weed was hit by the
weed zapper in general the main stem
might become necrotic but the lateral
growth was not affected by the
electricity so the weed might still
produce seed
we also found differential responses
depending on the physiology of the weeds
so in general we observed that the weeds
weeds that had a higher water content
tended to display more damage than weeds
with less water content
we also did see soybean injury with the
weed zapper
if the
weed zapper contacted that main stem of
the soybean the soybean tended not to
recover but if it did contact the top
few leaves of the soybean which you saw
in that video a lot of the top leaves of
the soybean were contacted the soybean
did tend to recover and produce yields
so now we've gone over the results of
this experiment we talked about we
talked about the cost of the tactics and
limitations
and so
I want to return to this topic of
multi-tactic management
so my experiment suggested that the
interro mower alone is effective at
reducing weed biomass and increasing
soybean yields in these systems which is
really cool and suggests that this tool
this tool can be used in this organic
no-till system
however if the interro mower is used
alone and repeatedly it could select for
low-growing species in perennials over
time
again we've seen this happen with
herbicide resistance where if only
herbicides are used weeds can adapt and
become competitive and resistant
so
this brings me back again to my the
design of this experiment right you're
placing stress on different weed species
and this will reduce selection for
adaptive competitive species in this
experiment the combination of the high
soybean seeding rate in the intra mower
produce the same results as just the
interim mower alone
this is just a consideration right as
Farmers think about which tactics they
want to integrate into their weed
Management Systems
additional considerations that farmers
can think about is the harvestability
how easy is it to access the grain when
um when performing Harvest
in addition weed seed production is
super important because if weeds produce
high amounts of weed seeds those will
drop to the soil surface and could
germinate the next year and you can just
get the weed species treadmill right
so can tactics reduce that weed seed
production
there's also the concept of weed seed
viability so there's been some really
cool research that has come out of the
University of Missouri Missouri that
shows that after using the weed zapper
you can actually reduce weed seed
viability by up to 80 percent
so that means that even if those seeds
do drop they might not germinate the
following year which will reduce that
weed seed bank so the weed zapper could
be a really great preventative tool in
these systems
and lastly it's important to consider
grain quality or if you have high levels
of weeds in your Fields they could stain
your grain but if you eliminate that
weed biomass Farmers could have cleaner
grain and higher profits
so to conclude
interim mowing reduced weed biomass
specifically annual dicot weeds compared
to the untreated control
tactics were less effective on perennial
and monocot weeds which offer additional
opportunities for other tactics to be
integrated
in the interim mower increased yields
compared to the untreated control
my experiment also suggests that the
weed zapper might be more valuable in
fields that have weed species which grow
high above that soybean canopy earlier
on in the season to be targeted by the
weed zopper
and lastly there's a potential for
additional benefits with multi-tactic
management Beyond just reducing weed
biomass and increasing soybean yields
and this is super important because
Farmers should start thinking about
how to increase resiliency on their
systems as we face more extreme weather
events as a result of our changing
climate and I think that multitask weed
management has the ability to do that
and with that I would like to
acknowledge the entire Ryan lab team for
all of their help and support throughout
my two years here at Cornell
um and also my friends and family
watching online
um thank you for supporting me over the
past over my entire life
um
um and yeah I'll take any questions
I will
I was just curious your thought on the
scalability of some of these different
Technologies and thinking about um you
know moving from the research plot scale
with
zapper and intro mower to an actual
commercial operation in larger machines
yeah thanks Debbie I'm just going to
repeat the question for the people on
Zoom so the question is
um what do I think about the scalability
of these tactics in large scale systems
compared to research
um yeah I actually think that they're
quite scalable and they actually might
um
when you're when you're in a larger
field the machine can almost travel at
um higher speed because then these these
experimental plots they were very small
right like 90 feet maximum so it once
you got up to the speed
um that a farmer could uh use the the
tool at you had to slow down because the
end of the plot was there so my thinking
is like if a farmer has acre and acres
and Acres of soybeans to manage they can
get going
um at a speed that will
um that will work for them
um
I also think yeah I mean you know it
depends on other you know so we found
that if the in the cereal right mulch
Fields with the high levels of mulch
there was less variability
um with like bumps and stuff and so
it I think it depends like if a farmer
is tilling their field how they're
preparing their their um
the bed of their fields so
um because that will affect kind of the
speed that the machines can travel
through the field and their ability to
Target weed species as well
very good question and people can hear I
confirmed online so people can know
one thing you know about the
semi's ability maybe I could say about
of those machines in terms like like
would it be possible to have a more that
could do like those like narrower into
rows like a 15 inch into rows or do you
do that yeah that's a great question so
I didn't mention this in my talk but
there is a company called the row shaver
row shaver systems that's coming out of
Kansas that is kind of looking at the
customer customizability of the mowing I
mean it is in general much harder to
cultivate in 15-inch rows
um I think you know Farmers have run
into that difficulty a lot when trying
to perform mechanical cultivation
um but if you look up bro shaver systems
they are yeah experimenting with
different ways so yeah
you can see that we worked at the
fabricator to design the interim order
that we used and it was based on a Model
that's used in Kansas first actually
narrower Rose so okay so yeah
all right let's thank Annika again
thank you
yes sweet so thank you Ichi and uh thank
you for everyone that is staying uh so
today I'm going to talk to you about the
research that I've been doing which is
investigating the effects of warming and
uh elevated carbon dioxide uh on plant
carbon use efficiency and this is a
global meta-analysis that I've been
conducting
so for those of you that do have to
leave at any points I've tried to make
this snapshot of everything that I'll
discuss and so I'll kind of go into what
is plant carbon's efficiency and what is
some of the prior research found next
I'll kind of go into what my research
questions hypotheses and methods are
when conducting a meta-analysis there's
a lot of statistics and data collection
that you have to do when you do this
sort of stuff and so I'll go into that a
little bit more in detail and then again
if you do have to leave the baseline or
main takeaway of the research that I've
found is that warming and elevated
carbon dioxide does not have an overall
effect on carbon sufficiency
but as you break that down into
different environmental and experimental
conditions it does influence the
response of carbon use efficiency and
lastly I'll kind of go into what are the
uh inferences or uh main conclusions of
my results and what that might indicate
within earth system models and
projecting the future climate scenarios
and what the carbon cycle might look
like in the next 20 50 100 plus years
so what is carbon insufficiency well
it's a conglomeration of multiple
different carbon cycle fluxes primarily
gross primary productivity net primary
productivity and autotrophic respiration
so gross primary productivity you can
think of is how much a plant has
photosynthesized over the period of time
and that's uh just based on a total area
typically
next is net primary productivity which
is how much carbon has been accumulated
into a plant uh after photosynthesis so
this metric does change under different
conditions which I'll go into and lastly
is autotrophic respiration which is a
plant will photosynthesize it also will
respires some carbon during that process
and carb use efficiency is that ratio
between how much biomass has been
accumulated relative to how much that
plant has photosynthesized over to over
a period of time and this metric has
been looked at quite extensively and the
reason why is it's quite variable it
does change a lot and we don't know
exactly all the reasons why
so uh this group in uh China found that
based on annual temperature Carbon
sufficiency changes relative uh between
approximately 40 and 60 percent and it
used to be considered that carbon
sufficiency remains relatively stable
however they're seeing that at lower
annual temperatures that carbon
sufficiency increases but as annual
temperature uh continues to increase so
does uh carbon sufficiency decreases but
they did see that's at greater uh annual
temperatures they did see that there's a
increase in carbon sufficiency again and
they hypothesized this might be due to
the leaf maintenance respiration
starting to acclimate to the changes in
temperature so there's maybe a dip in
terms of how carbon use efficiency
responds to temperature alone
next
um
researchers have been interested in
seeing how does carbon use efficiency
change under different nutrient
enrichment uh practices so if you in
increase the amount of fertilization
will carb use efficiency also increase
so this group ended up looking into how
does natural cropland fertilized and
elevated CO2 experiments change carbon
sufficiency and they found that natural
ecosystems at a baseline lower carbon
sufficiency value but as you start
enriching these ecosystems with a bit
more fertilization regimes carbon
sufficiency does increase and lastly
they were also able to observe that
under elevated CO2
conditions carbon dioxide or carbon use
efficiency also increased but they did
want to point out there's likely a
limitation to how much carbon
sufficiency may change under different
conditions and that's likely due to a
nutrient limitation or water limitation
and that might impact how carbon
sufficiency changes over a period of
time
and under future conditions
so that's very very brief uh overview of
introductions and so
um I wanted to get into as I looked
through all this literature I wanted to
see
um more and more about how temperature
changes and elevated carbon dioxide
concentrations influence carbon
deficiency because there's been some
research but it's not overall a uh
they've not done a global analysis of
how it changes and so that's what uh
um made me want to look at my first
research question which is just
understanding how does carbon
sufficiency and the elements that make
up carbon use efficiency change under
future
carbon dioxide concentrations and
temperature regimes
and so my hypothesis here with a little
bit of uh literature review is that
there are going to be some changes
carbon fluxes will change under future
conditions and that also will influence
the effect of carbon use efficiency
but we do know that the different areas
different different regions are going to
be more susceptible to climate change we
um
such as upper higher latitude polar
regions are more susceptible to Greater
increases in warming so I wanted to see
based on this
as we break that down into different
regions and different environmental
conditions is there a difference of
responses in these carbon fluxes in
carbon used efficiency
and similarly is due to plant diversity
in the experience experiencing different
climate regimes
the influence of warming and elevated
carbon dioxide will have different
effects on the carbon fluxes and carbon
insufficiency based on these
experimental based on experimental and
Regional conditions
so with any meta-analysis there's
typically a lot of data collection
there's
typically a standard protocol called a
preferred reporting items for systematic
reviews and meta-analyzes and so with
this you typically go to your web
scholar or Google Scholar or web of
Science and you insert your particular
interested
search items and so with that these are
all my search items carbon dioxide
enrichment face experiments so on and so
forth just to see how much literature
there is out there as you can see here
um I gathered 14 000 papers which is a
lot to go through were you able uh with
uh reviewing them and screening them
you're able to break it down into just
seeing how much of uh the literature
actually has variables that are
interested in for my particular research
and that basically boiled down to 68
published articles
um
and that's how uh that's this is where
my data is distributed across so of the
68 published articles I collected 48
different experiments uh ranging
um primarily within the Northern
Hemisphere and on different warming and
experimental types
so of all the 48 experiments there are
27 warming experiments and 21 elevated
CO2 experiments and for those warming
experiments they had different uh
different types of warming they had
infrared warming open top chamber and
what I classified as growth chamber
which you can kind of think of it as a
greenhouse experiment
and the average warming across them was
approximately plus two degrees Celsius
elevated CO2 experiments however
um had different implementation
strategies so they typically face
experiments or free air carbon dioxide
experiments are very common same with
growth chamber and OTC or open top
changer Chambers
and they increased carbon dioxide
approximately 220 parts per million
which is about 50 percent greater than
what we are experiencing today and as
you can see they are spread out across
um all over the world but it's primarily
folks in the Northern Hemisphere and in
particular ecosystems and bio regimes
and the treatment duration that they end
up experiencing range anywhere from one
growing season upwards of 15 years of
continuous manipulation
another common practice within meta
within meta-analyzes are reporting
response ratios or percent change which
is essentially trying to see when you're
looking at particularly warming or
elevated CO2
how much of that change is attributed to
that manipulative experiment and so
that's commonly done through a response
ratio
um and so to kind of walk through what
this actually looks like is you get you
gather all of your data and the hope is
you gather enough data that your data is
roughly normally distributed between
your treatment and your control uh
particular variable so gpp NPP Ultra
respiration or carbon sufficiency you
want it roughly to be normally
distributed once it is you're more
confident that the true population mean
lies somewhere Within These bounds
so once you have gathered enough data
and you start seeing this you are able
to calculate a response ratio which is
you take a pair of data so the same plot
same experiments treatment and control
and you take the natural log of the
treatment mind minus the natural log of
the control
and that gives you a single value and
once you are able to do that since the
difference only is based on the
treatment that you're looking at toward
the amount of warming you're given a
value and once you're able to do that
you do that across all of your different
pair of wise comparisons and you're
given a
response ratio distribution or frequency
distribution and so the important thing
is of course we want to see is warming
impacting these carbon fluxes or carbon
sufficiency and how you do that is you
see whether or not the mean is
statistically significant from a zero
response ratio if you get a response
ratio of just zero that means there's no
impact of warming or elevated CO2 on
that particular flux or carbon
sufficiency so that's a that's just a
response ratio
however I was very interested in uh more
breaking that down into subgroups or sub
categories based on ecosystem or
experimental type or duration and so
that's uh done through a weighted
response ratio measurement so again you
have your data and you want to see
whether or not a particular group
has an impact on
the
is a particular group has an influence
or changed relative to carbon flux or
carbon sufficiency and so you have your
all of your data and then you basically
categorize it based on a particular
variable such as ecosystem and once
you've determined which ones break down
into each subgroup you're able to do a
similar thing but it's weighted now
based on its particular subgroup in the
variance within each mean treatment
and once you do that you're again given
a response a weighted response ratio and
then you're able to take that and you
can also
signify based on a percent change
um so how much does warming change uh
this carbon flux or carbon sufficiency
by a particular percentage rate and
that's what these figures in the next
few slides I'll be showing
foreign
and the effects on carbon fluxes and
carbon sufficiency I want to kind of
these are the response ratios and I kind
of want to break them down into uh one
by one uh main findings so as we break
down gpp into the effects of warming on
gpp we see we see that it is
statistically significant from zero
warming did have an impact on gpp or
photosynthesis and
um it's approximately the root the mean
response ratio is 0.05 which if you
convert that back to a percent of change
it's approximately five to six percent
and looking at how my data changed is
it's changed approximately or increased
gpp by approximately 20 grams carbon per
meter squared per year which doesn't
seem like much but when you start to
consider that on a global scale that can
have a drastic implications to Future
conditions and carbon projections
next as we break down NPP and carbon
efficiency warming did not have a
significant effect on either of these
um
just warming just did not have any
impact on them
but we do see some extreme outliers
within NPP or accumulated biomass under
warming
in these extreme outliers as I were as I
was looking into the data were from
Tundra ecosystems that's uh reading into
the paper a little bit more they've
experienced uh major subsidence or
permafrost thaw due to this increased
warming conditions and that's the
researchers hypothesized is likely
influencing the soil composition or soil
nutrients
that might influence the amount of
biomass accumulation that these plants
are getting furthermore within this
tundra ecosystem plants are more
shrub-like and are likely more
susceptible to major changes in
temperature and so that might also be
what's influencing this drastic change
in uh NPP or biomass accumulation under
warming
next I want to kind of break it down
into particular variables so again I'll
walk through this but you have I broke
them down into absolute latitude
ecosystem treatment level treatment
duration and treatment facility so
walking through each of them
I broke it down into ecosystem and under
warming conditions we see that grassland
ecosystems had a pause uh were possibly
impacted or carbon sufficiency uh
increased under warming conditions but
um neither on on no other ecosystems had
carbon sufficiency values
but they did have different changes in
NPP and GBP for wetland and croplands
breaking it down into treatment level
however uh uh we do see that there are
some changes in carbon sufficiency so
you see at increasing temperatures
approximately less than 0.5 degrees
Celsius to about 1.5 degrees Celsius
warming above Ambience there is an
increase in carbon sufficiency
but no significant change to gpp or NPP
but as we increase the temperatures more
we don't see much of an impact on the
carbon fluxes and carbon use efficiency
so there might be a level to which
warming induces a positive or any effect
on these carbon fluxes and carbon use
efficiency
next is treatment duration treatment
duration really did not have any effect
on any of the carbon fluxes or carbon
use efficiency there is one variable uh
three to five years gpp it did increase
or was substantially different
um
but every other iteration uh every other
combination was not uh statistically
significant so these carbon fluxes and
carbon sufficiency did not change under
warming through prolonged warming
conditions
and finally uh treatment facility we did
see that uh infrared warming did have an
impact on carmi's efficiency and on net
primary productivity but other treatment
facilities did not have an impact on
these carbon fluxes or carbon
sufficiency
and that might imply that doing some of
these manipulative experiments that's
something to be aware of that they these
warming treatments types might influence
different responses to plant Dynamics
and carbon flexing
next just kind of looking into elevated
CO2 how to walk through it as a similar
way
so we see that under elevated CO2
conditions we do see that gpp and NPP uh
increase under elevated CO2 conditions
and this is supported by a lot of Prior
research and my
um
research supports this so we see that
photosynthesis photosynthesis increases
or gpp and then NPP or biomass
accumulation also increases under
elevated CO2 conditions and as we look
at how much to what degree or what
magnitude increases about 100 and 150
grams carbon per meter squared for gpp
and NPP respectively
however again looking into carbon use
efficiency it does not change there's so
there's not much of an increase of
carbon sufficiency for elevated CO2
experiments
and then looking into breaking it down
again into different subgroups we do
start seeing more of a change in carbon
use efficiency so the one I want to
point out here is that forests uh both
gpp NPP and carbon use efficiency are
positively changed under elevated CO2
conditions and that's uh could have
again uh interesting implications moving
forward because forests typically have a
longer carbon residence time because
these forests will accumulate biomass
into Woody biomass structures and that's
compared to croplands for example that
are harvested every year
that will have a lot longer carbon
resonance time
looking at treatment level we do see
that there is a also a different Trend
in these carbon fluxes and carbon
sufficiency so at lower
um carbon insufficiency or carbon
dioxide concentrations again NPP gpp and
carbon sufficiency do increase but
um carbon sufficiency starts becoming
less significant under greater carbon
dioxide concentrations however
NPP continues to be
um
more positively impacted under greater
carbon dioxide concentrations so there
that might
um also change how biomass accumulates
under future climate scenarios
and lastly looking at treatment duration
we see that
um treatment duration positively
impacted GP gpp NPP and carbon
sufficiency but primarily only impacted
NPP or biomass accumulation so biomass
accumulates
um more and more uh or is always
positively impacted by car music or by
carbon dioxide enrichment as it
continues going forward but carbonus
efficiency starts to not have as much of
an effect at a longer treatment
durations
and so looking at more of my data I was
wondering why is there a different uh
response between
gpp NPP and carbon sufficiency and I
wanted to look at what's the role of
autotrophic respiration is causing and
so as we can see here when we look at
gpp and autotrophic respiration is
autotrophic respiration increased more
under uh increased temperatures than
gross primary productivity and prior
research has shown that autotrophic
respiration is typically more sensitive
to than photosynthesis when it's
when it's
increased temperatures
um
autotrophic respiration is more
sensitive than photosynthesis when
temperatures are increased and that's uh
typically based on a overall Baseline
maintenance respiration increase
but we did see on prior research that
different warming facilities May
influence the change in autotrophic
respiration so if you're only warming
above ground that's likely going to
primarily affect Leaf autotrophic
respiration but not below ground root
biomass
respiration and so seeing different
responses in
respiration or gpp based on different
warming facilities that might elicit
different patterns depending on what
warming type you're doing
and then looking at elevated CO2 again
we see that autotrophic respiration did
increase under elevated CO2 conditions
but increased less
than gpp which was likely a reason why
we did see an increase in net primary
productivity for this sort of stuff
um
but maintenance respiration increased or
previous research found that maintenance
respiration increased under elevated CO2
this was an experiment that they looked
at how Ponderosa Pines under these
conditions change they just found that
an overall maintenance respiration
increase but not growth respiration
but if we do experience a net primary
productivity increase under
um elevated CO2 conditions that means
these plants are just going to have more
biomass that they need to account for if
you have more biomass you're likely
going to experience or have greater
autotrophic respirations uh right so
that might be one of the reasons why we
are seeing these trends
so looking at what my uh results show is
um or what the greater implications of
my results show is that there is uh
likely going to be a lot of different
vegetation and flux Dynamics under these
future conditions and improving the
understanding of how warming and
elevated CO2
uh impact future uh carbon cycle
Dynamics is important because we
typically want to
um
understand what the future is going to
look like and this is typically done
within earth system models and so if we
are able to understand what these
patterns look like currently
um we might be able to reduce model
uncertainty and we can become more
confident in what vegetation pools and
vegetation fluxes look like under future
conditions furthermore some of these
Earth system models have a fixed or
relatively stable carbon sufficiency
value
and that might not be as accurate when
it comes to understanding future carbon
fluxes and carbon vegetation pools
overall uh of course with many
meta-analyzes there are some data
availability issues or limitations and a
lot of mine has been uh based on
constrained to primarily Northern
Hemisphere ecosystems and just
particular ecosystems they aren't as
many experiments conducted in regions
that are more susceptible to climate
change as well as limited experiments
within Africa and South America and so
that's these patterns might not be as
widespread or as
overall the same pattern within these
regions
furthermore within doing this
meta-analysis it was very limited
exploratory analysis that I could do
based on other conditions such as soil
moisture soil nutrient type disturbance
regimes other ways to see how this
mixed analysis could elicit future
patterns and lastly when you do a
manipulative experiment that is quite
different than likely what we are going
to experience in the world when you do
this manipulative experiment you're
drastically changing the environmental
conditions by increasing it five degrees
Celsius over the course of a few months
rather than over the course of a few
decades it's not something to be aware
of when we uh take these manipulative
experiments into consideration is
just drastic versus gradual
environmental changes
so going back to overall
what my results have shown is that
Harmony sufficiency overall is not
impacted by elevated CO2 and warming but
when you break it down into different
environmental conditions and
experimental conditions we do see that
it does change and the reason why it
doesn't change overall is due to an
increase in
both a duality increase in productivity
and object respiration but those fluxes
change when we start breaking it down
into different regions
and
overall when uh the mass the main
takeaway is that understanding how these
carbon fluxes uh change we can reduce
model uncertainty particularly with
vegetation pools and vegetation fluxes
within earth system models and being
able to collect more data and understand
how these changes
how more experiments can improve our
understanding of carbon dynamics that
might help elicit future research when
it comes to manipulative warming or
elevated CO2 experiments
so with that I'd like to thank everyone
for staying for a very longer much
longer seminar and I'm happy to answer
any questions you may have
uh I thought it was really interesting
that your findings suggest that
respiration is affected by warming to a
greater extent than photosynthesis and
one of the reasons I think that's
interesting is that
over the years
climatologists have predicted that there
are some regions of the world such as
the U.S Midwest where the night
temperatures are more likely to be
warming or to a greater extent than the
day temperatures
and so uh so that would suggest that it
matters whether we're talking about uh
you know X number of degrees warming in
the nighttime just the daytime I was
wondering whether the meta-analysis you
did had uh experiments that
differentiated between uh warming during
the night and day
yes there were some uh there was one
particular experiment uh conducted in I
believe mainland China that had
different changes in warming based on
day daytime warming they only warm
during the day they only warmed at night
and then they had a consistent 24-hour
warming and there were changes in
autrophic respiration I unfortunately
don't remember that Valley off the top
of my head but I believe there were
Baseline changes to particularly
maintenance respiration
um under uh nighttime warming greater
than uh daytime warming
but yes
um I was wondering if you came across
anything first congratulations
you came across anything that compared
the responses to say like C3 versus C4
plans
breaking it down into uh the particular
C3 and C4 plants uh overall we I did not
find any uh papers that were looking
particularly at differences in C3 and C4
um that also is somewhat limited within
my met analysis research is they didn't
particularly account for all the uh
Community uh plant types but that is
something that would be interesting to
see what the difference in C3 versus C4
plants under future War Mainer elevated
CO2 what how they each respond so
unfortunately don't know the answer but
uh yeah that's definitely something
interested to look into
listen
I'm a social angle but it seems like
your research should be suggesting how
important it is to be looking at it not
necessarily on a global scale and really
zooming in on some of the environmental
differences you talk about how it's
unfortunate that there's not data in
four locations globally but I wonder if
you have any
thoughts on how you you know how how do
you have any ideas on how people can
focus in on the area they live in or
whether it's not a Country-Wide scale
nationally but how do we try to get at
some of those differences that you're
talking about in terms of
so you know it might be really different
if you're living somewhere that has a
lot of tundra or has a lot of wetlands
or grasslands you were pointing out
right right
um on a more social aspect yeah that's
that's for the research though yeah for
the research
I don't want to just say the I come from
a modeling group so I don't want to say
the typical model of things and like oh
people need to do more experiments uh I
think from a more model perspective we
need to be more aware that
um how we weight different parameters so
how photosynthesis or biomass
accumulation within certain
ecosystems and how we weight
ecophysiological and biological traits
um might help improve our understanding
and reduce that sort of uncertainty
within those regions so
of course there's there's a benefit to
doing more and more manipulative
experiments in these particular regions
particularly those more prone to climate
change but there's only so many more
experiments and data that we can collect
before we we as modelers need to
um
accurately capture and understand how
this is changing and accurately
parameterize them so
I don't know if that answers your
question thank you
Marcus and the um
[Music]
different experiment yeah
like the composition of the experiment
would change so if more people were
trying to do studies in the tropics
if that changed
with this basically a ship the overall
effect to something that is
right right so
overall like when you look at going back
several slides sorry
um looking at something like this if you
have more of a region that is more
susceptible to
um elevated CO2 or warming it might uh
skew the results
but the hope with doing a male analysis
is you've collected enough data that the
true population mean does not differ
when you collect more and more
um data so the hope is like if you get a
tundra ecosystem that's highly
susceptible to changes in temperature
they might be way over here or way over
here but hopefully you've collected more
data across the globe that does not
influence or does not skew your results
and so it's it's a matter of collecting
enough data I would like
I don't know if that's getting at your
point or
I might be also a little confused with
your what your question might be
yeah I was wondering like if you could
change
in different regions
right
right it absolutely it could so as you
as you collect more data within
particular ecosystems that will change
these plots a little bit more
um
so the more important but that would
mean in other words that the second
conclusion that it does change if you
look at the different outputs it's more
important than right
because that would mean okay if you had
a different set of experiments that that
would change the competency but not
the second one yes
nitrogen
volatile
and that would influence also um
yes yes there there have been
um
research doing the changes in elevated
CO2 and
or warming and changes in nitrogen
composition water availability all that
sort of stuff but the the difficulty
with that has been
um not every
article has published or has that
available data set and so I'm unable to
analyze how that has changed
particularly across all of these
experiments is seeing how nitrogen
mineralization or
nitrogen content changes under these
conditions but yes there have been
experiments trying to see how these
changes in warming and elevated CO2 do
have an effect on plant nitrogen content
and plant water available or water
availability so yes
all right thank you very much
um
questions
yeah yeah well thank you I appreciate
that
yes thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu